so I have a question mm-hmm  you are showing me a picture on your  phone yesterday yeah and I saw you  scrolling and I saw that you had a  dating app installed on your phone have  you been with anybody else while we've  been talking over the past four months  no okay can you just let me know why you  still have a dating app on your phone  yeah I still have one of the dating apps  because there is a business networking  side of that app but I don't use like  the relationship side of that okay well  I mean would you be open to deleting the  up if you don't have faith in me then  how is this gonna work you know I'm I  don't think it should be such a big deal  to just delete it  and that's what I'm doing right now  because he told me to stuff asking me to  delete this app suggests to me that she  doesn't trust me at all and I think  she's going about this in a completely  inappropriate way  [Music]